hello welcome for the continuation
so that's the big room
for big data
so all the sessions in this
room it's going to be on the deal and we're going to
start with a quick overview of
big data products after there will be
spanair y sessions  aura machine learning
au rabbit query so this is the right
room this is the right place
my name is william monette i am a
product manager i am responsible for
the product manager team for data
processing and in this game session
gave a  quick overview and after guest
philippe girolami from dailymotion and
didier girard two spheres who will
talk in a very concrete way about
the application of safe products on
projects at dailymotion to
contextualize big data
a way of thinking about it it's true and
this photo  that's street view I
think you recognize
it's a photo in paris so
somewhere in the 1st
arrondissement originally street view when
it started ten years ago  was
only a google maps feature was
no it would be nice when people
look at a map to show them
what the destination looks like yeah
good idea come on we put cameras on
the cars and went around the
big cities originally it  was
just the big cities now
it's of course a lot more a lot
more places and and that was an interesting future
what changed drastically is that
now not only do these images
continue to be used in google
maps
obviously but  there is a lot more
value in the data of these images and
what has changed is not the
images themselves
good i guess the resolution is a
bit better now than ten
years ago but basically thats  not
that which is what is the big difference the
data is the same what has changed is
the environment
these are the tools that allow to analyze
the data is therefore in the case of street
view mainly d  e
image recognition but that's only an
example
in general data analysis tools
have become much more
sophisticated much easier
to use and are available on the
cloud
which makes them much
easier  an opera operationally
and that's really what changed
big data technologies the cloud
and the union of these two dynamics has
completely changed the landscape is strong
forces us to reassess the value of the
deal is the same data that doesn't  has not
changed has more value now
because of evolutions
so when we think about that what
high data we are talking about there are four
main quadrants there are data that
you are already using today
so it is well known in your
data warehouse  and you'll get tired of it
you know it you get value from
it there's all the data that you
already collect but that you do
n't read for various reasons they
went there  onner that you do
not collect that you could collected but
as there is no use for what why
the snares why collect them
today maybe now you
have to reconsider this decision is
finally there is a huge category
of  data that is given which is
not an oath the one you produce
but it is which you might have
access through your partners
public data commercial data
you might buy etc and so is
now with the convergence of big
data and clad  you really have to
rethink the given strategy and
ask yourself what value is
available but the promise years old when i
say now it is it is doable there
are a lot of barriers that have been
removed the friction but is much
less than is what  it means in
practice
in practice a big data project until
recently it was a haiti project
it was a project with all these all
these aspects that had to be on the  table
and it was necessary well how are we going to
do that what resource what are
we installing how to manage how
laurent louis the album on will be
global deployment etc
and it is therefore without sound without having any
claim of exact size of the
different  part of the camembert
was the kind of thing you had to
deal with but really the only thing
and brad explained during which our
right before the only thing
you really want to deal with is bring
your own value your business value
your  knowledge of the problem
your knowledge of giving it and that
's just the little piece of
pie that's on where you
create your costs and rice or you create
your processing code and that's what the
cloud allows you to do  is
specifically the google cloud because
from the beginning it was built on
a let servers model i.e.
it's not ucla version 1 which is
yes i take what i have between m
and i do  turned  r on vms in the
cloud that helps with
saeed provisioning with nothing else
big data services on google cloud
are cerebellum services this or
really you all the constraints and
all
the administration responsibilities are no longer on
your shoulders are on google's shoulder
that's what we've always done
that's what we've done very well your
responsibility is just to bring
needs and therefore you
only pay  is on the level of ease
of use
it's much simpler because
all that has to be done is the business part
plus it allows for
much greater efficiency because our server model
lets you only pay
that what you use there is no
risk of having servers that are
there waiting for them to do nothing and then
one day the volume goes up then all of a
sudden here are these servers that did nothing
now they're green l'oder and
they don't know what to do
sorry for the anglicisms to i have been living
in california for 20 years so they
tend to creep a bit soulful and
so the in a model servers
leaves if you don't use you do
n't pay when you use more
automatically the service increases
ramps up for you and you
use you only pay for
what you use so i
gave a few examples of
server services la sorgue oklad one of the things
that is very interesting is that its
services they are integrated
so i will  talk about pop sand
dataflow from big willie and are not
just silos but they are services that
support a flow of data and from
start to finish
it is in server mode leaves which
allows to overcome operations
so let's start with pop sable which is a
perfect example of a server service
functionally leaves pop seube
and is nothing original and not
only to Arab peoples
it's been 30 years or even can  e more than
that we have a carpet that we send
events have made a subscription we
receive the observed events so
they don't invent anything on the functional level
it's a known pattern useful where advertising
and revolutionary it's on  the
operational plan with pop tabs literally
all you have to do is
what i just wrote create a
topic for you
what does it mean it's a
command line these two clicks on the
web and  the squire topic title it exists
it's a resource
you put permissions on it who has
the right to post who has the right to
subscribe and you're done you can
go on vacation the topic it's there
if there isn't  of message it costs you
nothing it is just there to wait
when the messages start to arrive
automatically the topic does its job
receives the messages the sendings with a
lolette thus with a short delay
sends them to all those who have
subscriptions and have done their
p work  ub increasing according to the traffic
and therefore we have clients at more than a
million messages per second on a
topic who have nothing to administer
all they have to do is create the
topic and receive the  messages so in
addition it used remain safe global from
google so wherever the source of the
message is the message is captured on the
point of presence nearest google network
goes on fiber google
fiber international fiber networks to  at the
datacenter and bring down a
colossal system that you have access to without
having to deploy having the
kafka clusters that you have to have at the right size
and that's so that's a good example of
servers leaves applied to
conceptually simple problems  evandro
koering after pop are typically what
you have to do is analyze these
events and so if the source is pop
job we want to do that in stream mode
if the source is something else like
files in databases  born
we want to do this in batch mode that's
where dataflow comes in dataflow is also
a product this setback leaves
data analysis to run popes so he tries revol a
pop up scan
that means that
at the same time  refit difference end of this
park there is not a dataflow cluster
each job is a separate resource by
itself what you do is wanted to
place a job is run this job
for me in batch mode or a mode  stream
is automatically the resources
the job needs are provisioned the
job is at all it is and
all you have to do is
develop the job a so i go i
said it was match and  of the stream
that's the other important aspect
dataflow in addition to the brain aspect
leaves it's the ability to take the
same pipeline that runs at an early age and
in stream and that's really very
important because not only  we
need both but
doing both with the same  not
exactly hovering is what allows
companies to gradually evolve
from a batch approach which is
relatively dominant to the
stream approach which is
increasingly common whether it is because the
sources change to become in film mode
or that  new sources arrive like
aliotti like and mobile
applications sources which naturally we
see strings of data is therefore if your
pipe line the same step plagne can
work in batch and in stream
it allows you easily without having to
reimplement your logic of  adapt
when the sources change to adapt the
sources and continue to projects
analyzed give it and that to other
applications for ml the same when you
when you train a model it's
often in batch mode so you have to prepare
the data you have to  a pope lane in
batch mode to prepare the data
to train the model once
you have a model and want to switch
to prediction mode often it does
n't happen  runs in stream mode
but the data has to be prepared
by the same punch line for the same
model to be used
so again is taking that pipe line
and running it in stream mode is very
useful internally the google we use this
for  about for machine learning
to do the preparation to give
that sum back to go forward
has so what i'm describing the alignment of
the programming model between down from
stream actually it's something that was
unique date to  float but which is no
longer so because we have it open source and that
's something we do a lot
you're an e seems more blind-test in
water heaters in general google
com like sam  the dcri google shares
the innovation and therefore for data flow
we shared it at birth announced in
a patch which was during this
transition it was renamed to patxi bim
and bim the bc batch and the mc stream so
another one  both
the unification of batx and stre  am who has a
model that the fundamental discovery
of this model is to accept the fact that
they have two notions of time there
is time in the real in reality
the time when things happen when
the  events really happen and there is
the time when the the object that represents
the event happens in your pipe line
and its two times they are they are
different in an ideal world everything
would be on the diagonal the events
would happen immediately is in order
in reality  it's not the case and that's
the main source of the
historical difficulty of streaming and that's the
problem that bîmes as a
programming model has solved by offering a
model that accepts and that this
dichotomy and that allows  amodu the
laughing stock the code to explain
how to use it so I can't describe
bimes in detail there are plenty of
resources fights at patxi bim the site the
apache dabbachi site sorry that describes
his but it's really fundamental
because  it was  it's made in open source
it's something that is no longer
unique to google and that was the
goal we didn't want to keep it unique to
google  model itself we do
n't want them not worth it to be
unique and so now people from
cloudera have joined us who have made
what is called a runner for this park
which allows bim applications to
run in a cluster this pack legends
data artisans have done the same for
flink so there is a runner for flink
also has a pure apache apex and google
cloud data flow in this context is just
one option among many it's
another environment  in which the same
pitch bim plane can be deployed to
spin what is different for data
flow is that it is a savior cloud service
lets you don't have
kloster but functionally
it really is an option like any
other
one  well bein very very powerful but
it is  a development tool for
developers there is java indicated there is a
python our friends spotify create one for
this case there is a pogo coming
so you have your choice of language
but it remains for developers for
those or in  situations you do
n't want to write code
we have a product called cloud data
prep which is a graphical product that
can be used by anyone who does
drag and drop or who can use a
spreadsheet that allows for
interactive composing  by interacting
with your data to compose
pipelines of preparation of giving to
fetch attributes in a
url or in a management object and
so on to harmonize the addresses etc
what is very interesting is that
data prep well below what  fact
is that it generates a dataflow pipeline
so at the operational level it's dataflow
you have there the infinite scale
the auto skelling the server still leaves
because it's from there  you have blurry who is
under date after date after is just a
wall around it features typically
there are a lot of storage systems
but typically for analytics the
storage system in which the
data arrives is big willie and
so it's  on this afternoon in this
room entirely on big yes that I
really invite you to which invites you to
participate in big three in summary it's
one of your winehouses for the cloud but
which is only created for the cloud
again it's  not a
traditional system where you have hamada terroir
aoc this cluster
it has twenty machines with while
being cpu and i pay for that and it
limits vicquery capacity it's completely
different
it's an ocean of infinite table so
you can add  tables you
create tables you put
new data in the tables
either streaming or with laudes and
you pay exactly for what you
use so you have five hundred 500
guy g  abas 500 terabyte we have people who
have more than 100 petabyte in big willie
you pay exactly per bike ready for
what you use you have not
provisioned in advance
and the same for queries send you
packages for a few seconds
or minutes  for the very big
[ __ ] that the aco and rip rank iliad
is maybe thousands of accounts
that are assigned to your query as soon as
the crisis is over
these bodies go away you only pay for
what you use either for each  query
individually or a fixed price per
month but again without having
set up infrastructures and
benefiting from incomparable performance and
scale another
serving product leaves its cloud emails and there
again there will be sessions in this room
on machine learning so
I'm not going to go into the details of
what it does but in summary it's a
water heater service for
trading
gift of model training to
make  the prediction on the domains
which allows you to use an
open source interface time on flo which is also
open source like bim and therefore in and
portable outside of google with the
possibility of using its on the
optimized infrastructure of google which has
was created specifically for this and
is in a way to connect with all the
other services so no one uses
tenchu flot in isolation to use i
needs a data management it needs
to prepare the data it needs to store
the data so al
the services that are  usef
for big data in general are useful
for machine learning and all the
work you do in your big
data projects to bring and prepare the give
it also prepares you to
do analysis with my learning chains on
the platform
another principle  which
increases efficiency on the platform is the
separation between data storage
and analysis so for storage my
day and then I could have b  as m
database different tones spanair for
example could be the cloud sticks to it
but the three systems that are
typically most used
for large scale analysis
sego cloud storage
for object storage big yes that I described
previously  for tables and beat
them'all for the no6 glue so the
storage re flocks a jump
in these cases what is very
interesting is that all the
data analysis tools have access to all
the tools  storage so you do
n't have cécile or huy this data is
in the data warehouse and this data
is in the hadoop cluster and this
data is in the hours file or in
another system etc and you have
to permanently move the data
to use the tool you want
on google cloud the data is of which
the most appropriate storage system
after if you want to do data flow
cloud data flow is able to access
all these systems where a scanner or
to  other systems and so you do
n't need to migrate the data and you
access it where you want even bikkuri
itself obviously big willie if
you described several petabytes
discovered huge input
they will be more efficient if the
data is  in be curry the
storage system which is optimized for this access
but you can run sequel
big willie anywhere you have
files in our towns cloud storage
you have tables in big thebaux the
same documents from google drive you
have a csv file in google drive
you have a spread [ __ ] in google
drive all of that is accessible by big
willie all you have to
do is write a glue that can
make games between all these
sources and  very easy way to
get access data to all that
remains that she another
example each time I come back behind
another example these data proc that I don't
have so I haven't yet talked about date approaching
our hadoop faux parquet service to
allow you to take
the investment you may have
in your home with fences this real park
with jobs sparks kolding cascades
inc big eyes all you could
use
to bring the easiest way
to bring these jobs to google cloud
is to run this park and radu can
therefore the same so obviously compatible
with all that this park will be doubled by
data proc
on the one hand it is this paradox they are
the same the same  dapatch goals that
everyone runs except that
we start a cluster in 90 seconds
except that we pay per second and except
that there is no need to bring the
data into kloster the milk the
programs are unable to access
directly to the data including cloud
storage in be curry in beat them'all
etc so really that changes the
way radio works because it
allows the use of very
dynamic kloster where you can make a cluster
that is not used  read only for a job
for a day or a week
maybe just for a group just
for one person and we don't have all the
problems of having to share 1 kloster
who lives for months and maintaining
the cluster  and patching it etc.
we can keep a cluster for
months if we want but in practice
people very quickly change to a custom
mode which is much more dynamic
for clusters on gotthard
now let's quickly talk
about visualization systems and  two
main ones that are integrated into the
platform in addition to that of all
the partners who can only offer
it for the platform but as a
system to google one its data lab which is
for data scientists and in this
area there the  notebook this songs
are a dominant access model zhu
peter specifically is probably the
most most famous most used
attacker notebooks this data lab
adopt jupiters to sedhiou peter
tourn  ant on the cloud is configured for
easy access to bille query at claude
hamel so really my parents very
easy for this net attackers
to use the platform and all the
products inside a tool with
which they are familiar
in this  regarding what is more of a
business audience or frankly
anyone in the organization a
new product is called data studio
which is a reporting and
dashboarding product which is who and fruits which
is free what is what
they never have a problem and which
really helped to democratize access
to giving it is something that is
very easy to use there is nothing
to install it is entirely on the web
and  it allows anyone in
the organization to create
visualizations and share them it
uses google drive's sharing mode
so you can very easily
share with everyone in your
organization or with certain people
with partners  areas in other
companies and it's really that it
's something that we see spreading
in the organization and changing the mode
of collaboration to focus and on the
data between people so here
it was a quick overview
again  once there will be sessions
on be coheris on machine learning that
render in more detail
but rather than spending too much
time describing these things
in theory what i would like to do its
guests philippe girolami and didier
girard to talk to us in a way  very
concrete of what they have done with these
tools for dailymotion
hello to all stronger at 6 billion
hello to all
didier and myself you go into the
details of all the concept cars has
swept go to these last minutes
william thomas has you  already showed this
a few minutes ago so we're not
going to review I'm an
architect at dailymotion so for the
past few months we've been working on
how are we going to set up
again  things following the launch of
the platform and in particular
everything related to the
personalized recommendation for that we
called on to be done who helped us
in the implementation
so we are a group of
developers we are four  cents
we've been using the google code platform since 2008 so it's been quite a while we've been on the gc pays we're first on the ground we also have we're also
autores trainer we have a stand so the
best way to get to know us and come
to the  booth you have three reasons to
come to our booth it's one wanted to
win at google aum
we have about twenty that we distribute
you are a developer you are looking for a
good job this is a second good reason
and 3 you are a customer he had  a beautiful
project to entrust to us here is meeting
on the stand whereas they knew
logo in data session I think that there are a
lot of people who know our
cantons that it is the present of
many people  when we say when someone says
I have to build a data the people who are
reflex is to say to themselves well I'm going
to go to the apache foundation
I'm going to download a set of
products and I'm going to start
building the world at tallec
it's pretty much  fter a six-
month project and after six months
this team has built its
precious and it's something quite
complicated to implement
here's what we're saying now is that
rather than saying d  'go to the
apache foundation and download plane
bundle the idea is to say to all
this slightly complicated part which
is the configuration to manage
patches and that's all the idea is
rather to  outsourcing to a third party is to
focus on value as
williams explained earlier
happened on an architecture that is
server let so it's
server architecture let they will take care of
everything for you l  idea is that you are
going to focus on what
creates  value for your company it is to be
read the analysis of the data is therefore a
classic architecture it will
take products which will collect the data
is therefore pop soul in server leaves
tools which will be used to transform
this data
data flow we will  working on
information
flow and storage products so spanair storage him qu
harry and bigtable chasing the
classic architectures that we implement
so we are now going to talk about a
specific case which is dailymotion so here
we are at dailymotion  wanted in two steps that we will
show you being able to set
up personalized recommendations
the needs what it was first
to collect the deal and be able to do
that what it typically gave what
video you watch what have  been your
search keywords
how much time you spent
watching a certain video we
needed to collect the data
but how we want to do a
recommendation that they be accurate
we need our data to get
to where we need
it quickly we can't wait an hour we ca
n't wait for the log file
you kindly collected ken
genic to be aude and  in your date
alec
so we have a quoted bike problem
that we need to fix to be able to
provide recommendations i watched
a football video my next video it
's probably not going to be the
snow queen and it needs to  we know that
you watched football until just before
the last point reminds me of the one that
françois de la redoute mentioned which
is once we have created a
data set in a data lake there are a
lot of  team in the company
who will be interested and at
dailymotion we realized that
with gcp we could give
all these teams access to the forms and
show them that it is how to access the
data schemas explain to them
how the  requests and and to make it
no longer a silo of information that
they were only available to the
data is visible to others through a
prism or through fitr the last
constraint we had is that
dailymotion is a very large
platform and to serve its
customers worldwide we have
to distribute our datacenters and we have
three at
google+ in paris and one at others which
are in the process of being opened,
so the solution for  implementing his
recommendation was obliged to take
this into account and it
seriously complicates the problem so in 2000
in 2016 2017 in 2016 our architecture
to do similar things or
just analytics was crowded batch
with double until then we have to
having trouble jing we have a lot of
great things we're teenagers problem with that
is first we were on a
schedule ingestion and the second was that so
we were only on sister
parties we had in  permanence at least  an
hour late if not a little more
spent collecting
information over several hours so
that's really the idea of data the aic in na
ale and what is the princ
ple it is you have rivers that
conveys the nuggets its rivers in
fact you are going to collect everything
that is conveyed you put it in a
huge lake which is increasingly
vast and then after you
launch huge jobs which will seek to
filter this information in a way  to
recover the nuggets
that's the idea it's really the idea of the data
eak so to develop this archi
ecture we wo
ked on a project in two phase
the first phase was to recon
truct this data leak what
e  wanted it was more a lag in the
differences that was going to have it was
more like tallec in which we had
an hour of latency to
have deals and fresh but it was to have a
dat to go that towards which we were going to
have  information rafina bhl
almost in real time, in fact, that was
really the idea, then after the second
phase, it is to work on the flow
of information in order to create
added value in real time, so to
build an infrastructure that makes it possible
to create  datas the two real times
we will rely on what is called a
clar de tel so it is produced and
already been presented widely during
this morning
you will see them again so first
thing you put in pop seube pass
of a people  that's what williams said
is very simple
my dad he knows how to set up a
pop up topic which to go to the
console and say I'm afraid that a
seube pop topic and behind it is able to
collect a million messages per
second only ultra simple to implement
and then once it has done that it
goes away and it's over the fra structure of
google will take care
of keeping any message that has been
transmitted in infrastructures secondly
and bahia when  you collect  ez
the information there are always little
things to do even if you say I want to
store the information in a raw way
if you still have a very little
processing to do on it
so it's always good to say to yourself I
'm going to put a little  process data flow
which can eventually begin to
detect outlier data
things like that add a little bit of
value but really very light and taken
behind you store in a big three
bichari it's a real-time data leak real-
time data warehouse we are  capable
of streaming and hundreds of thousands
of events per second in a
vicois table nothing that's really it the idea is
once the information was
deposited in big houari they are
immediately accessible in query
for that we say that  'we are on the data
reader is she so here is
concretely what it looks like we
process 3.5 billion events per
day through this pipeline which is
completely hosted on s  ur gc pays an
interesting point that didier underlined
knows that in dataflow processing we
can do little things for
example to enrich
each event that happens is enriched
cocan it concerns video sorry it is
enriched with the title of the video and a
a certain number of other fields why
because we no longer need to
jog behind for the vast majority
of our processing
the data is immediately available,
that is to say that between the
moment when a telephone or a browser and
but  the event and the receipts on pop
sober and the moment between between pop seube
and the moment when we can regret
it happens a few seconds at most on
my part I never managed to generate
events while I was doing
tests at  not see them in the big aubry
when I was dreaming
riffing the results
so that was the first part of the
project was we'll see it was
built pretty quickly we had
now  Having our dates with real time,
the idea of what follows is to say well if we
want to create value in real time to cr
ate business in real time becau
e we have to, it's more than
aiting  that the information is in
the lake to analyze it why should
n't we analyze it
directly on the flow of information
that is arriving
so that's really the idea of
econd part  of the project so
basically it's the same
architecture okay it's just that you've
always connected your information with
weak pops and then the brick transforms
which will precisely create value it
's just going to be a little bit more
sophisticated so  it is simply at this
level that we will begin to analyze
the data and create value for
the business in fact, so the use case
for us is the
recommendation engine.  we should
introduce you when you come to the
site
so we went  realize that I
'm going to tell you about two things that we
do among all alone if we
realized that they had two
interesting markers to use for
the recommendation the first is
what are your last requests on
the search engine  research but also in
which video and to engage you that there
are lots of people who start
watching a video then it stops
immediately, on the other hand those you
have watched to the end or the one
you have  watched 80% or 50% these are
interesting markers so what you
have to see is that when a video is
viewed on a browser we have
time signals that tell us the user
is still watching
the user  is still
watching so we have a stream of
data coming through its pipe lines that
looks like streams of data to a
tool telling us that they
allow us if we consolidate them to
know when the video was still
view and we  serves as a data flow to
do that and behind build a
model of recommendations and behind
serve the recommendation for a
given user so what does it
look like in architecture since we
did it entirely danger cp we find
what we saw what  'we have clients
in the first stage I don't
need to go over it
here we build the model and we
reuse some of the tools that
williams talked about
we use victory which has
very fresh data to extract certain
relevant data that we put  on cloud
storage cloud m it uses this
cloud storage data came out of
that we have a machine learning model
which is also stored on cloud
storage
we will see what is missing a little
later we use its model the second
part the architecture  is to say
well I would like to be able in real time
to update a database of my
visitors in order to have my
entry vector for my machine model
real time learning i really want to
know as soon as he did a search
bam
my data model is updated as soon as
he watched a video at 80% i want to
have seen that because i know he is
very  interested in football, for example,
how do we do that well, we mainly have
the events
received, we hijack a part of them, which we
redo as needed in a second
data flow 'pipeline' and this second pope
linedata flo does fairly complex functions
that are  'call the windows then
in this case we use windows
phone which manages in particular the notion of this
cube in the east between the time of arriving
the time of generation of the events
that williams was talking about earlier the
second thing which is  done
once we have built the
updates that must be applied to the engine
of this forgiveness we must apply to the
user database
we must manage to distribute these
updates in all our data centers
we have three distributed in da  ns the
world for gcp we can't just
start doing updates on the
remote database since we have
too much latency to do that to be
able to distribute both the
updates we use pop seube which is  a
global solution with very low latency
and which makes it possible to beat in the
data distributions and finally in
each datacenter we have a last per
fuzzy linedata which receives through its
own succession so there we have three
substitutions for each our
datacenter receives each event from
which describes the update to be applied
in the visitor database which is
also replicated in each datacenter
that's for the streaming part we
also have so here we go then we put
the two in common we have an api that we
use in  internal in our site which
regularly receives model updates
and which for each request on
the country makes a request to obtain the
input vector for this this user
and passes  r its part the
machine learning model
we have models that are updated
every 5 minutes with a system
like that that poses no problem
for us so for the proper functioning of all
this so as not to have operational problems
to have to manage in
permanently we do a
catch-up match every evening we extract the
data again from doe town hall we
determine it in the same way as we did
in the first dataflow job at the top
right
kate his book
the fisher who describe this user and we
reapplies its to the database in
important ways so as to
never have a gap between all the data
centers this is a template for how to
set up a
recommendation solution on gcp including geodis
tribute here is everything  that we used
I think we will find almost
everything that williams described we
used pop sober to connect the
systems together and to distribute the
deal and geographically we used
fuzzy heaps as a streaming engine
to perform complex
data aggregation operations I haven't
talked about it on the previous rooms but we
also use as an author of baigts
when ray applies the
nocturnal beh on the user database
we use google cloud storage as a
system global file storage is
accessible to all systems of the
biko eric architecture as da tallec
and as a source for
error recovery all of this runs for a few
endless moments most of what
I described to you running in the
managed services we have a few it's a
few instances for example the country
that respond to requests for
recommendations it is hosted in
qu berne and s cloud and but it is
used to make the machine
learning model and  we monitor all that with taxi
driver so there we will see a little
bit what the results are and then some
small practices that can help you
to put to put  implemented a solution
like that and some attacks
so the first thing I told you was
setting up this famous
real-time alex date it was two weeks
after two weeks we had switched
the production flows from the old
system to new systems
don't tell yourself that setting up an
infrastructure like that takes a long time it's
extremely quick to implement
so that you really have to keep that in
mind it's not projects that are
long and  so if you want to do
mvp things like that it's done
really very very quickly in fact
so after two weeks we had
the data which was regrettable in
real time and from that
moment there is  had all this work
to build the engine of as a
recommendation which the true value of the
system in the end and which of course takes
a little more time secondly
how we work roughly we have two
chains we have a chain on which we will
test d  so we have two gcp projects a
gcp project which is more for
the ladies in which they go than an
exact replica of what will be in
production but which is on data which
is not real data
okay but that  allows all
developers to test and deploy
what they are working on
and then after we have the live channel in
fact so you have to have these two
environments minimum
it's quite simple to implement
so we are promised mountains and wonders
on the  scalability and well that's great
wonder
I put you some examples of
how things soto has just for
example on the left you have the diagram
which indicates the number of instances which
have been started or stopped by gc pays
on one of our '  pipeline' dataflow what
do we see there we see the seasonality
of the ddd yven arriving on our
platform since we don't have we are
not always at the peak
fortunately the example at the top right
you  indicates a case where we have  it
interrupted our processing pipeline
so in pop seube the messages
accumulated you see that we climbed them
without any problem up to 4 million
finally I have already seen tens of
millions of them and then we restarted the
'pipeline'  so we see that lacan the pac
blind has turned on again the messages
started stacks and so not
only do we manage to take the
charge and stay at least constant
but we even start to help him crushed and for
a moment it stops abruptly
why because I have cp to
automatically start more instances in the
pipe line
it's transparent we
realize that when we look at the graff
we don't need to do
any action on it once  'we
arrive at the very bottom gcp will remove
some of the instances because it
realizes that it is overcapacity at the
bottom right you have a diagram which
shows our consumption on big willie
in terms of this batch which you do not want
go into detail
what we have to remember here is that we
have multiple projects that hit the
same
date each color is
a different project so
different users and we see that
it goes up it goes down it adapts to the
load and again we don't
have engineers who need to
supervise this system we don't
have engineers who need to do
very advanced capacity planning to
know  when to buy
machines in advance and as a snack pixies and all
that thank you
after so a little in terms of feedback
there is a subject that is
still quite difficult so it is almost
impossible to implement when you
do it at  the hand it remains difficult to
put when we are on the service it is
the stability side when we speak on the
spot if you have already heard
of abbey testing so the b testing
is when we are on an engine  of
recommendation so this
low recommendation engine when we change we
want  e to be able to test it on a
sub-section of the population so as to
validate that we do not have to break the
recommendation so it remains things
or the fact of being on an architecture
serves their purpose it greatly simplifies
the deployment request  it's abb's systems
and testing but it's not yet manager
as we might wish so if
I had a request to make to williams
and that one day we can do b
testing on this kind
of  infrastructure it would be really great
conclusion in conclusion what do we
have what were the positive points of
our experience with gc pays first
we met all our needs we have this
freshness of the data we had no
problem to implement it in terms
of speed so we manipulate the
concepts which become a little
complicated in particular on data flow
there is notion of temporal but we did not
have to focus on a few is the
streaming engine choose which
platform
da tallec etc and  then it scales finally
we have no problem we put 35
billion messages per day in
this database we make
requests without any problem thanks to
partitioning techniques so we
have to be smart we try to
avoid jo rin  when we need it but
we also do lefts every day
we even create crowds of john height and it
works like hell so to remember
we have improved the velocity of our
data between the time the date has been generated
on a site on  a telephone or on a
browser and the moment we can use it
or even the moment when it was put
in a model it is ready to be
returned for a recommendation we are
talking about minutes of minutes and again
it is because there we  has models
that can be updated every
few minutes
second point to remember is the interest
of starting on these server architecture
let it simplify your work
it will bring you velocity
and perhaps a  from  points which is also
extremely important so I followed
more generically at sfeir as I
wanted to say we currently process the
applications that we deploy process
about 1 million events per second
it allows me to sleep easy and
that's probably  one of the most important things
here is thank you
[Applause]